wahrscheinlich hat es kaum einer von
ihnen mitbekommen aber unser bundestag
hat heute über die ki strategie der
groko diskutiert also über künstliche
intelligenz ganz wichtiges thema denn
mit der menschlichen intelligenz die
sich ja leider nicht mehr so weit her
meldung aus dieser woche der lungenarzt
köhler großer kritiker der
abgasgrenzwerte hat sich mehrfach schwer
verrechnet gibt da selber zu er sei halt
durch die tiere rentner und habe keine
sekretärin manche sachen kannst du dir
nicht ausdenken ja noch mal zur
erinnerung der mann der neulich in
sämtlichen talkshows saß und den die
bild regelrecht gefeiert hat oder wie
man bei p&g da sagen würde
premiumpresse ja dazu zu sagen wir mal
matte geht natürlich kein wort von
verkehrsminister scheuer
kurz gesagt wir brauchen wirklich
dringend mehr künstliche intelligenz in
deutschland einer hatte allerdings noch
zweifel
nicole scott meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
hallo in meinem leben haben maschinen
schon alles unter kontrolle wenn mein
smartphone mir zum beispiel sagt ich
will jetzt das update durch dann sage
ich nee bitte nicht im maschinen sagt
doch und ich sage okay
dieses capture system das macht mich
auch fertig kennt ihr das wenn man im
internet unter den neuen kacheln aldi
anklicken muss auf den ampeln und auto
oder ein schild zu sehen ist ich spiele
das manchmal eine halbe stunde ist
dieser pixel jetzt eine ampel oder nicht
woher soll ich das wissen und wie viele
runden muss man spielen bis man endlich
weiter kommt ich finde dass capture
verfahren demütigend warum muss ich denn
der maschine beweisen dass ich keine
maschine will ich glaube das ist die
vorstufe davon dass die maschine uns als
haustiere hält wir lassen hunde ja
kunststücke machen und geben ihnen dann
eine belohnung und so macht die maschine
das hier mit uns auch sucht die kachel
sucht die kacheln und dann kommt bekommt
man am ende eine belohnung und darf
bezahlen im supermarkt gehen finde ich
auch schrecklich wenn ich mit einer
pfandflasche in den supermarkt konnte
ich an die grenzen meiner fähigkeiten
ich gehe dann zum leergutautomaten du
meine flasche da rein und er sagt mir du
hast die flasche falsch eingelegt und
ich denke nur älter du hast die kuh von
andererseits weiß der experte für fand
flaschen
und dann beobachte ich mich so von außen
wie ich an einem mittwochnachmittag in
einem handfesten konflikt mit einem
leergutautomaten stecke wofür irgendwann
den supermarkt mitarbeiter hinzu der mit
er unseren streit schlichtet der
mitarbeiter legt die flasche ein
der automat nimmt sie an und er sagt mir
hast du wohl falsche eingelegt erst
arbeite ich kostenlos für den supermarkt
mit
und dann mache ich das noch nicht mal
gut ich weiß nicht wie ich nach so einem
erlebnis noch erhobenen hauptes durch
den tag gehen soll
danke
[Applaus]
manchmal fahre ich mit autos zum
nächsten auftritt und autos habe ich
festgestellt die beobachten einen die
ganze zeit neulich meinte ein auto zu
mir
müdigkeit erkannt bitte pause machen und
da war ich auf 180 natürlich dann noch
auf der autobahn nach hinten auf die
rückbank gegangen und nickerchen
einlegen
das hat das auto aber auch gemerkt mich
zurückgepfiffen dann habe ich die
fenster geöffnet und frischluft reihen
zu lassen und dann gab es eine nico tipp
luftwiderstand doppelpunkt fenster
schließen
nico tippner also ökologischen hinweis
und da dachte ich mir
das lasse ich mir von volkswagen nicht
sagen guten tag könnte ich sie für ein
abo des heute show youtube kanals
begeistern schließt gefälligst ein abo
ab sofort